[Music]  please lord  make me the biggest star the world has  ever known  so that i'll make it far far away from  this place  caring for your family during these  times is admirable  but you only get one take of this life  if only they would just die  pardon  nothing  later  [Applause]  i want to be special dancing up on the  screen like the pretty girls in the  pictures  i'm worried there may be something real  wrong with me rumor has it they only  take one gal per town  we're looking for someone with x factor  how about a film nobody else has seen  it's illegal  will be eventually  i know what i've done  bad thing  terrible awful murderous things  i want to be loved from as many people  as possible  but truth is i'm not really a good  person  nobody else  [Music]  you